but first he is the former District
Attorney for the Southern District of
New York he hosts the cafe podcast stay
tuned with Preet Preet Bharara all right
such a silly monologue such a serious
person I enjoyed the monologue very much
oh wow I can't say those things no you
can't well you couldn't you can on now I
can't yes now you can you free from you
got a big job you're the US Attorney for
New York I always said the US Attorney's
will like the Senators of the justice
system there's about a hundred right
yeah sort of more like the governor's
okay but of our domain masters and in
New York tell us why New York is more
important probably than any other day
well so there are four districts in New
York southern eastern northern what you
know following the direction I was he
was turning the Southern District of New
York
whilst retains Wall Street it contains
lots of businesses it has gangs like
other districts have and it also is
probably the greatest target in the
country for terrorism
that's where 9/11 happened right in part
so we're always focusing on on those
kinds of issues and also it has probably
the most media presence of any place in
the country so anything that happens in
Manhattan and the surrounding you know
suburbs gets a lot of attention
call me had your job Giuliani had your
job yeah he did have my job what do you
make of Rudy Giuliani and by wider
extent the whole Republican Party right
now I don't know what your politics are
you're you're a serious public servant
that's secondary to what you do but you
must have seen a different Republican
Party until two years ago as we all have
I mean those are separate questions what
has happened with Rudy Giuliani and the
Republican Party I guess they sort of
overlap a little bit look we do Giuliani
was well they're both Ewing and they
they're both enablers for a traitor
nope Giuliani is supposed to be a
professional lawyer and for six and a
half years I did it for seven and a half
years for six and a half years was the
US attorney in Manhattan for the
Southern District of New York
I'm had a great reputation um some
people thought he went too far in some
cases but he was a trial lawyer by
training and understood what integrity I
think in in speaking about cases in
court and outside of court meant
generally but some of the things that he
said just viewing him as you know a
former colleague and he was very nice to
me when I took the job I had dinner with
him to get some advice from him and in
recent times I think he's taken on an
aura of someone who doesn't remember
what the truth is doesn't remember what
he said about issuance of subpoenas 20
years earlier who doesn't remember that
the people he used to work with
including folks in the FBI who helped
save New York and figure out and people
in law enforcement yeah he'll save New
York and find the bad guys he now calls
them stormtroopers because he's trying
to protect a particular president not in
the way that he was trained to do and
not in a way that he trained generations
of federal prosecutors to do so I gotta
tell you it's fairly disconcerting so I
saw you when I said traitor you looked
like you were uncomfortable with the
word I tell me why we're not saying that
word more because I mean we are being
attacked by Russia even presently you
would agree with that right that's my
understanding
okay well if if the president is taking
the side of the people attacking and
he's certainly doing that when he goes
after the people who are defending us
from those Russian people he belittles
them he criticized them he tried him he
threatens to arrest people like Jim
Comey one side or the other why that
word trust me I've been I've been a
pretty vocal critic of the president in
various forums
I think he's leading a corrupt
government I think he's doing a lot of
things both corrupting people corrupting
institutions corrupting processes
corrupting but I could have said that
about George Bush well no I could have
said he was a karate King that night and
over water Assange was a writer an order
of magnitude difference
I think the yeah look there were the
words treason and traitor have
particularly GLE meaning and so maybe
I'm an overly careful
recently former prosecutor a for it who
wants to be overly careful at this moon
right maybe not and if people want to
call folks traders I guess that's fine
the worry I have sometimes just as a
private citizen now I'm not speaking as
a lawyer is you know you can subject
yourself to criticism if you are sort of
overstating and I'm not saying
necessarily are but if you're
overstating what other people have done
and it allows folks to be dismissed a
little bit more out of hand when you
when people yell treachery and treason
well they don't they don't worry about
that and they're winning
I mean he's purging the ranks of the FBI
he's going through them one by one it's
like us I keep saying slow moving coup
some people said this week it was like
the Saturday night massacre but slowly
he's slowly going through the ranks I
mean he got rid of I think I saw seven
of the eight people the Jim Comey had in
his office to corroborate as
corroborating witnesses what Comey was
telling them about his meetings with
Donald Trump
what would your office look like if
seven of your eight top guys were gone
it would still be pretty good actually
really yeah because you know what so
that's a deep deep state you go by deep
state if you mean professionals who are
consummate professionals my heroes
understand yeah what continuity means to
understand what the Constitution is
right so don't care about party who
don't care about politics right just do
what's right and and honor the law and
honor the Constitution then God bless
the deep State but he's purging
okay so so you could lose your top eight
people how many could you lose it would
not be great to lose your top a people
know it's good to have the top managers
but what people need to understand is
personal by the way I think that the new
FBI director is an honorable and good
person I think we accidentally got a
great person to be the head of the FBI I
think he could do better I think you
could defend the institution better I
think you could speak up about the kinds
of things Trump is doing more but I
think what you have happening here both
with rod Rosenstein and with Chris Rea
who's the director of the FBI and some
other folks and I don't necessarily love
it but they're they're sort of walking a
line between try and defend their
institution and do what is right and
also placating a guy who freaks out and
gets angry and upset and could fire you
want to win so some what some people
might call and I get it
some people might call that weakness and
say you got to stand up to paralyzed you
might say I'll get that but for me being
here yes then things would be a lot
worse I think there are lines and I
think you know when we had Admiral
McRaven this week who doesn't serve in
government I believe it who comes out
and says mmm it was a quiet guy who
wrote a book about how you should make
your bed right and how little things are
important when he comes out and supports
in solidarity someone like John Brennan
who out of pique and and whim and anger
and retribution by the president taking
away his security clearance that that's
the kind of thing that matters and maybe
we need to see more of that from not
only people who were in government now
and serving the executive branch now but
also members of Congress I know you care
a lot about normal
this is mr. president doesn't care about
norms if you don't write it down he will
he'll just go ahead and say I can pardon
myself or I can no he he has ways of
being petty nobody been thought of
nobody even right nobody even thought of
withdrawing people's security clearances
no founders did not appreciate that
there was going to be at some point you
know they worried about a lot of things
and they worried about self-interest and
they worried about you know self-dealing
is under a king yes
he's wants to arrest Omarosa and why I
don't know we'll figure that out
litigator because she spoke out against
it I usually embarrass but again but
this is not something we can just say
well I will laid all the facts to kabuto
I just think everyone's too calm about
this situation there's the old saying
why'd you forget to go for the King you
gotta you gotta kill the King right so
it's fine to me metaphorically
[Applause]
metaphorically cuz really the secret
service please please don't come yes
they will because they will do that cuz
they're crazy well ice work with a
Secret Service and they're all crazy but
not them but the rhetoric is fine and I
think it's there's an important role I'm
a private citizen now and I talk about
these things you talk about these things
there's an important role for for anyone
in the public sphere who has a
microphone to talk about these things
but the people who are gonna make you
know a difference other than at the
ballot box which is probably the most
important things they're not to you know
you know downplay that but the mother
investigation no Bob Muller can't stand
up and say treason in an interview he's
got to collect the facts
he doesn't say an interview yeah that's
good that's up to the Democrats Rudy
Giuliani's on TV every day they get
their story out but we don't get our
story out
does anyone listen to Giuliani says
unfortunately they do yeah yeah but all
over TV and just because you're on TV
doesn't mean you're believed just
because you're on TV does mean you have
credibility because because you're on TV
doesn't mean you're doing a service to
your client but he muddies the waters
would you disagree with that that's what
they're good at that's what they're good
at
yeah good we got to get good at
something yeah
but I'm not sure I'm not sure that I
know you're not saying that if they
muddy the water you know that when they
go muddy we go muddy or no but I don't
think right no but but we are bringing
not even a knife to a gunfight we're
bringing a covered dish and it's just
honestly anyway I'm glad you're around
and I hope you get back in the game
thanks very much all right thank you
free Ferrari